-You had your kids on set.
-Yeah.
-7, 10...13?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Here´s a photo of your kids.
-Oh, yeah.
-They´re very adorable.
-I haven´t even
seen that picture.
-And they were on set with you.
-They were on set with me...
-I think for that clip.
-...for the clip
that you guys just saw,
which is the introduction
of my father, John Lithgow.
And we are --
we´re very open, loving...
-Mm-hmm.
-...father and son relationship.
We kiss every time
we greet each other.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the scene they
got to see for the first time.
Which I -- I forgot that we were
shooting it that day,
and my boys were like,
"What is going on?"
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Well, is it funny?"
"It´s funny,
but it´s embarrassing."
[ Laughter ]
"How many more times
do you guys gotta kiss?"
And I´m like,
"We´ll do it all day long."
"What?!"
[ Laughter ]
"We will do it all day long."
Yeah, so, uh...
They thought it was --
-They learned that --
-They were like,
"Dad, your job´s embarrassing."
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-I know one of your kids
recently asked you --
He´s obviously smart
to know that this is a thing.
-Yeah.
-He wanted a gap year.
He wanted to take a gap year.
-Yes.
He´s in 8th grade.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And, uh...
He said,
"Hey, dad, I think, uh...
I think I want to do
a gap year."
And I go,
"Between 8th and 9th grade?
Like when?
Right now?"
He´s like, "No, no, college.
I want to do a gap year."
And I´m like,
"Oh, well, you know,
I think that that´s something a
lot of kids are talking about."
´Cause, you know,
it´s hard to really know
when you´re 17, 18...
-Sure.
-...what you want to do, and,
"Yeah, if you want
to go get a job or work for
the, you know, Peace Corps
or do something like that,"
and he´s like, "Work? No.
It´s called a gap year, Dad."
[ Laughter ]
"You just hang out."
I´m like,
"You do not just hang out."
[ Laughter ]
"You have to do something
constructive."
He´s like, "You don´t know
what you´re talking about."
[ Laughter ]
"It´s a gap year."
So that will be
an ongoing argument, I think,
in our household, yeah.
-Well, I hope -- You know, I
don´t know who I´m rooting for,
but I hope you guys
figure it out.
I want to talk to you about
this, because we´ve done
a very popular segment
on our show,
called "Second Chance Theater."
-Yes, which I love, yes.
-So we´ve done it --
I think we´ve had 605 shows.
I think we´ve done it
three times.
-Okay.
-So it was very popular.
[ Laughter ]
There´s a sketch of yours
that I remember
right when I started "SNL"...
-Yeah.
-...it was like a thing
that we would
all gather around and watch.
-As one of the biggest failing
sketches at dress of all time.
-I, uh --
And it is --
When you explain it,
it will sound like something
that should fail,
don´t you think?
-There´s no question.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It´s based on --
-It´s based on --
I wrote a sketch
about a guy who dresses --
looks exactly like Gabe Kaplan,
who was the star of the hit
sitcom "Welcome Back, Kotter."
-"Welcome Back, Kotter," yeah.
-He was also
a professional gambler.
-Uh-huh.
-Side note.
[ Laughter ]
And I wrote a sketch
where it was --
I worked
for an insurance company...
And it took place in a
break room, and everyone was --
It´s the day
that Gabe Kaplan came to visit.
-The real Gabe Kaplan.
-The real Gabe Kaplan,
and no one came to get me
out of the bathroom to meet him
´cause I was his biggest fan.
-Yeah, right.
-And judging by the silence
in this room, you can tell...
[ Laughter ]
...that it didn´t work then,
and it will never work.
But that´s why
we need to bring it back...
-We have to bring it back.
-...for "Second Chance Theater."
-Well, here´s the thing
about it.
´Cause the interesting thing is,
you realize the core
problem with this sketch
is that no one --
there´s a lack of recognition
for Gabe Kaplan...
-Sure, for Gabe Kaplan.
-...right off the jump.
-Super...
-And now it´s been 17 years.
-Super obscure
late ´70s reference.
-Yeah.
And so now time has passed.
You would argue that,
if anything, he´s less known.
-Less relevant.
[ Laughter ]
-But you´d be willing to come
and do the Gabe Kaplan sketch.
-Oh, I would in a heartbeat.
Yeah, yeah.
-And I´d say the reason
it was great to watch
and why we all watched it,
is you never waned at all.
-Right, right.
-You committed fully.
-You know, I have a tendency,
for some reason,
when I could tell --
when a sketch was tanking,
and I could tell
the audience was like,
"Let´s just get
to the next thing,
" I would take twice as long.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I don´t know why,
but I wanted
to punish the audience.
It was like, "Okay.
You don´t think it´s funny.
Now you´re gonna really
not think it´s funny."
[ Laughter ]
"´Cause I´m gonna turn
this three-minute gem
into a eight-minute turd.
-Yeah.
-And you´re gonna have
to sit through it.
-And most of the dialogue...
-Yeah, yeah.
-...is you saying to Horatio,
John Goodman, I believe...
-John Goodman and Molly
and Tim Meadows, maybe.
...is just a lot --
You just keep repeating, "What?"
-"What?
Why wouldn´t you come get me?!"
[ Laughter ]
"My life
is all about Gabe Kaplan."
So, yeah, I really --
-Next time you´re here,
we´re gonna break out
the Kaplan mask...
-Done. Beautiful.
-...and go to work.
Thank you so much
for being here.